قنابل تركيه خطه عليها اسماء ضحايا تفجير
اسطنبول الدامي تركيا التي تحمل حزب
العمال الكردستاني المسؤوليه عن تنفيذ هذا
الاعتداء سنه هجوم الجويه على مواقع
المقاتلين الاكراد في شمال سوريا وزاره
الدفاع التركيه قالت ان الضربات دمرت
ملاجئ وانفاقا ومخازن للذخيره ومعسكرات
للتدريب وانها حيدت العديد من من وصفتهم
بالارهابيين فبالنسبه الى انقره حزب
العمال الكردستاني منظمه ارهابيه وحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه في شمال سوريا ليست
ان امتدادا لهذه الجماعه المسلحه قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه التي يشكل مقاتل وحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه جسمها الاساسي اقرت
وقوع ضحايا في صفوفها وافادت بسقوط ضحايا
من المدنيين بالاضافه الى مقتل جنود من
الجيش السوري التابعي لدمشق المرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان تحدث ايضا عن حصيله ثقيله
من الخسائر البشريه 35
احسن بالغارات الجويه التركيه على كل من
الحسكه والرقه وحلب كما توعدت قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في بيان بالرد على الغارات
الجويه التركيه وبالفعل لم يبقى الجانب
تركي بمن انا عن التصعيد فقد تعرضت قاعده
عسكريه تابعه لتركيا في ريف حلب لقصف
صاروخي وسقطت قذائف صاروخيه داخل ولايه
كليس المجاوره لسوريا متسببه لاصابه
ثمانيه من قوه الامن بحسب وزاره الداخليه
انت وغلط ثلاث مرات داخل الاراضي السوريه
بدعوه محاربه المقاتلين الاكراد لكنه
هجومها الاخير اقتصر الى الان على ضربات
الجويه والقصر المدفعيه